mit klaren worten richtet sich
un-generalsekretär antonio guterres an
den syrischen machthaber baschar al
assad angesichts der lage der
zivilbevölkerung in ost guter forderte
einen sofortigen stopp der angriffe
ich bin zutiefst betroffen vom leiden
der zivilen bevölkerung in ost guter
400.000 menschen erleben dort die hölle
auf erden vor unseren augen spielt sich
eine humanitäre katastrophe ab und ich
finde nicht dass wir dies einfach so
geschehen lassen können
nach dem willen schwedens und kuwait
soll der un sicherheitsrat bereits heute
über eine resolution abstimmen
die eine 30 tägige feuerpause in syrien
fordert diese soll humanitäre
hilfslieferungen in die umkämpfte region
sowie die evakuierung von verletzten
ermöglichen
allen internationalen appellen zum trotz
bombardiert die syrische regierung seit
mehreren tagen die region ost guter
assad scheint entschlossen die
rebellenhochburg unweit der hauptstadt
damaskus zurückzuerobern
nach angaben der syrischen
beobachtungsstelle für menschenrechte
kamen bei den kämpfen in den vergangenen
tagen mehr als 300 zivilisten ums leben
darunter viele kinder